okay let's go next to our caller from
the eight/three to area code caller from
8:32 who's this hi my name is Daniel I'm
based Eastman Texas great what's on your
mind today what do you see to be the
most drastic changes the Democratic
Party has made since 2016 and what do
you see as necessary changes for the
future moving old since 2016 I mean I
don't know I I don't know that I could
tell you anything that they've
necessarily changed I mean I guess
they've they've decided that rigging the
primary wasn't a good idea I don't even
know that that's true like I I'm not
have they made any changes since 2016 uh
I don't I don't I I don't know that
they've made any changes I think that
this is part of the problem what can you
think of a change that the party has
made Pat's
more accepting of Medicare for all for
example yeah more there are there are
more debt but it's not it's not a
Democratic Party policy now that there
for Medicare for all
I mean listen I think the change there's
always this discussion of should the
Democrats play to the center or should
the Democrats move to the left and I
think that it's a it's a relevant
question but it's not actually relevant
in every race I think that as I've said
before depending on where you're running
for example we had a primary earlier
this week for Senate in West Virginia
Democratic primary joe Manchin
considered widely to be the most
conservative Senate Democrat in the
United States he won his primary what
makes sense for Democrats to do in West
Virginia is not the same thing as what
makes sense for Democrats to do in
Massachusetts which explains why we have
one of the most progressive senators
here in Elizabeth Warren you've got the
most conservative Senator in in West
Virginia so I think the change is that
the Democratic Party needs to make on
balance are to just embrace and actually
move to the left not the corporate
Democrats but progressive Democrats but
I think that big picture they need to
understand that the strategy is not the
same in every district or every race the
same way Republicans understand that all
right the next one for all right Daniel
thank you glad glad I was able to answer
your question appreciate the call